Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Clustered.
Today, we have another Rawkode
versus the community. Only today,
I'm not fighting alone. I will introduce my
guest in just a moment, but before I
do that,
a little bit of housekeeping.
If
you wanna win a t shirt, which of
course you do, you can go to Rawkode.live/win.
Go there,
enter the competition. We will draw the t
shirts at the end of the episode.
Next up, I wanna thank our sponsors.
We have been using Teleport since the second
I would say first, but it's actually the
second episode of Cluster, way back in January
2020.
So I I wanna thank Teleport for their
support. You should go to Rawkode.live/Teleport
to learn more. We use it every single
week. We pay our it gives us access
via GitHub authentication to SSH, to databases,
to applications.
It's truly a wonderful tool that should be
in everyone's production and maybe even non production
environments.
So go check it out and watch us
use it today. It's a whole lot of
fun.
Alright. I see the chat's having fun too.
I also want to thank Equinix Metal. You
can find out more about Equinix Medal at
Rawkode.live/metal.
Going to these links helps the sponsors and
helps me.
So go learn more about Bare Metal Cloud.
If you don't wanna pay for it, because
why should you, to check out Kicka Tires,
use the code Rawkode.
This will get you $200.
Now we use Equinix metal every single week
as well since the first episode.
Bare metal clusters are the best. We have
tons of cores, tons of RAM. It is
a whole lot of fun. Now I could
use small instances for a cluster, but it's
a lot more fun to use big chunky
ones, and maybe we'll get to see a
look at the cores and RAM later. But
that is awesome.
Alright. Thank you, sponsors. Now I said I'm
not fighting today's episode alone. I'm gonna introduce
our wonderful
I don't know if I wanna call you
a guest or a victim, but either way,
welcome, Marek. Hey, man. How's it going?
It's going well. How are you doing?
Believe victim is correct terminology, by the way.
Is it? Yeah.
Alright. Well, for I mean I'm sure people
have seen you before on this, but why
don't you give us the introduction to Marek?
Yeah. My name is Marek Houns. I'm super
humbled to get to do this with you.
I learn something new every single time I
watch one of these. I think it's fantastic
and I appreciate you doing this.
I don't know if none of you know
much about me. I'm
a fellow YouTuber.
I also try to help people but I
don't ever run a live show quite like
this one. This one is very special.
Yeah. And
I just entered to win a free t
shirt. So that's what I was doing during
that introduction.
Awesome.
Well, depending on how badly Russell and Kevin
scatters today, I may have to send you
one as a sorry anyway. So we'll see.
I do love that they're, you know, they're
all talking at the chat about Russell's
sort of build up psycho tweets over the
last three days.
Scheduled tweets are the worst thing ever. I
have come to determine that.
That's horrifying. I I got to wake up
since I'm like behind time zones. Like, that's
was my morning tweet feed was like Russell's
scheduled tweets.
Well, here's the the latest one. Not a
tweet, but a comment in the chat. There
are 23 hints for today's cluster for Russell.
I hope Russell's better at giving hints than
I am. Last time I got I got
flamed for my tweets.
Or not my tweets, but my hints. So
hopefully he's better than I am.
Yeah.
Awesome. Russell also stated Barack's content is also
awesome. Yeah. It really is. We'll get a
link to that in the comments. Feel free
to drop that in there, Matic. Share it
with the with everybody.
Alright. Well, there's no point in delaying the
inevitable. We should take a look at our
first cluster.
So let me pull my screen share up.
There we go.
We have Are we hitting Kevin's first? We
are gonna have Kevin's first. Yes. So I've
done a t s h l s. I'm
listing the notes that belong to Kevin.
I am
gonna join Kevin
control plane
one.
That session will be started in just a
second. Please join that when you are ready
and give me some sort of echo or
l s or whatever to let me know
you're there. And already we have Kelsey.
Nice touch, Kevin. Thank you very much.
Really quick question. How do I list sessions
in the command line? I'm gonna try the
command line instead of the web. Oh, you
can't. You have to get those session ID
from the web. There's a feature request to
do the session listing, but it hasn't been
done yet. And there's a good reason
that I wanna dive you know, divert off
course here.
But what you'll see is when you go
to the active sessions, it will list sessions
for all clusters, even ones you don't really
have access to. So you'll actually see the
there's some stuff I'm doing with e b
p f d for at KubeCon. Uh-uh. And
they're fixing the the scoping of this API
before they release it to the CLI. So
but you can grab the session ID from
here.
I know that's a a long answer to
what you want to do here, but there
we go.
And I'll just join it for both in
case we open them.
So did you use the the web or
did you use the CLI?
I used the web. I'm gonna flip over
to the CLI and I was gonna try
to do that in the background while
yeah. Alright. I may oh, well, let's let's
start talking around this first cluster. So this
is broken
by
Kevin, very active member in the Discord community
and also in the YouTube comments as the
fire flash.
So
let's see. I will export our kube config.
Alias k to kube control.
Just out of curiosity,
looks like
looks like that's maybe alright.
Should we cat it to see if it's
a binary? That's how I determine if something's
a binary.
Well, I mean, I don't I I don't
trust these two. Like, these two have seen
a lot of clustered episodes. They know a
lot of tricks, and I'm gonna be checking
all the basics today on everything.
But at least, like, kubectl as binary
potentially in the right location,
We have a version that looks like what
I would expect. We got a server version,
which means that our control plan may be
alright. I'll give you the owners if you
wanna pick your favorite command and hit our
control plan.
Alright.
Not too bad. Not too bad.
I'm
actually kind of worried that that worked.
Like,
this is a bad thing on my part,
but I
I'm kind of worried, like, this is, like,
some default engine x reply or something.
No. No. No. No. I don't I don't
think so.
Let's try get pods service, and endpoints.
The holy trinity. Right?
Pods look good.
Service
looks good.
Employees look good.
Is that are we being too confident here?
That's
what I'm saying. I'm feeling worried. Okay. So
maybe we should
I'm gonna open ProPlayne is not ready. So
I would actually check out cubes
the cubelet. See what why the cubelet is
not
Well, we do have the v one image.
So
that that that's a good start.
Let's go back here.
So shall we just
well, we just try updating the v two
and see what happens?
Okay. Yeah.
But the control plane isn't
healthy.
Well, the node isn't healthy, but the control
plane is responding to request.
I guess.
K. That's it.
Edit play.
Clustered.
There's that weird thing.
Told you that would come up.
Do we have a working cluster?
No.
We have a.
Kevin says, loosely, I forgot to check one
thing. Damn.
Alright.
Tell you what, Kev, feel free to jump
back in. Check what you need to check.
I will edit my deployment back.
Come here
to
right. We've rolled that back. You go make
whatever change you need to make, and we're
gonna move on.
You want me to check the kiblet?
Alright. Let's do it. Let's our mission is
not to update v two on this one.
Let's get that control plane happy.
So
we have a not ready on the control
plane nodes. Marek, what you wanna do?
Alright. So if we have not ready on
here, then what we really probably need I
would check the cubelet logs
to or maybe just systemctl,
the status there.
Will we describe
the node first?
Sure.
Yeah. I guess since it's responding, there's no
reason not to describe it.
Let's see.
So there's a bunch of unknown. So this
would say that the cubelet isn't
talking here, the node status.
Yeah. Which I think you already kind of
thought anyway. So why don't you start digging
into the cubelet?
Alright. So
Oh, there's that that's not right.
That's fantastic, by the way, but not right.
Does our kubelet just curse at Yes.
So we have a deprecated warning, but that's
not really my biggest concern. My biggest concern
here is I don't think that this is
a real cubelet.
But you ran a system control command, right?
Oh, yeah. But this is the cubelet logs.
Right? Right. This is just going to be
its logs out here. We could actually just
check the logs. Just do like a journal.
Yeah. And this actually prints it out a
little bit better.
Yeah. That's a problem.
So there's two possibilities that my mind jumps
to. First, that this is not the right
cubelet.
And we could look at
one second. I'm looking through this printed out
a bunch of
garbage.
There is the we try to figure this
out and he's injecting log messages. So it's
actually a type of attack is injecting log
messages
where
you don't sanitize user input into log messages.
I don't know that he found one of
those in the cubelet. If he did, you
should actually be reporting that. So my hunch
is that he actually just compiled his own.
Compiled his own cubelet.
Okay. So how can we Cool. Convert that.
I mean, we could search on a cubelet
version, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Cubelet version.
That was like a cubelet.
Don't think it is a cubelet.
No. I don't either.
Where's that beta ring?
I don't know.
We could check when it was last messed
with. It should be the same age as
the machine.
Uh-huh.
Let's do that.
X-ray.
Yeah.
Alright. So everything
oh.
This is interesting. Things have been messed with,
I think.
I shouldn't have printed out the entire directory.
That was kind of dumb.
Well, looks like CAF was working on this
just forty minutes ago. Nothing like a last
minute break.
So 07/2006
or seventeen o six, April twentieth.
I'm
curious of the strings command. Well, I mean,
I expected to put it as cozy, but
I wanna see it.
Yeah.
It's not a binary.
I should have cat it. Like, I I'm
telling you, this is what I did last
time. I was like, it's not a binary.
I'm just gonna cat it.
And then I cat it a binary.
It's a mooplit. He's he's given us a
mooplit.
Very nice.
So can we just go pull?
Let's just do an app to just reinstall.
Well.
Is that not work? No. Don't don't cat
it. Don't Do your string. Do string.
Oh, yeah. String's always gonna do.
Yeah. That's better.
So why did the restart
Maybe it's just a hangover. Nope. It's not
a hangover.
You Wait. Do we need to do like
a daemon reload on system CTL?
Only when you modify the the unit fail.
Right.
I would have thought at least.
But all our system control commands are. He's
not just modified Kiplit. That's the problem here.
Did he actually modify
the system c
system d?
Or did he do the system files?
Oh, look. System control was compiled today at
five past five.
I've
never reinstalled this DNLive system before.
Surely that's gonna blow up. Right? No?
There we go.
Do you wanna run? Get notes. You think
it's happy?
Or are we gonna have to list every
binary modified in the last ever?
It's not
we might have to list every binary that's
been modified. It still says not ready, but
it might take it a second
sometimes.
Let's define user ben dash m
three six o t
fail.
I just did a modified time. I thought
it was just seconds.
I don't know, actually. Let me go Google
it. I'll Google it.
It's dash m time space.
M time.
And that's just type f.
Okay.
Oh, and then that's a
forward predicate, so maybe. Yeah. Like negative.
Yeah. I don't think he's compared to all
those.
Alright. He's in the chat. We found all
the binaries.
Alright. So our
kubelets should be posted in a status at
least there.
Should be.
Let's see. It still says kubelet stop posting
node status.
We have a kubelet running.
No. We don't.
So now we should probably just get its
logs from it now. I I would do
you mind if I type real quick? No.
Go for it. Alright.
Let's see.
Yeah. It looks like it's starting.
I think the daemon reload mod is only
needed when you modify the unit fails. Oh,
actually I I had a misspelling
of cubelet
when I did the logs anyways.
So
I do believe that there's some
this isn't your typical thing that you get
exported out in logs here.
I think possibly the system
file has been updated with how it runs.
Let's see.
Let's see. Its exec start here is
the kubelet,
kubect config args.
That almost seems right.
Wait. Wait. Insecure values.
Maybe we should check its
configuration file. Well, mean, the environment fail is
pointing to the mid blitz though.
Oh.
Oh, sorry. I hadn't scrolled back down to
where you were.
Let's take a look at the mid bloop.
Run once.
Oh, that I knew that was gonna make
another
appearance after the last day.
Wonderful. I have hurt myself.
Past Merrick
hurt current Merrick.
Well, we still have the Etsy kubelet files.
So I guess if we go to
systemd system
kuplit,
where was the fail?
Here.
No. This is configured
here. Yeah. That is the right one.
And
No more mooblets in here. Right?
We should have just started a find on
the file system for mooblets.
Alright.
Still not QIPLET.
That was unexpected.
Okay. So it's on this roll and restart
thing. It does have a restart ten seconds
in the config.
So it's not getting enough.
Oh, sorry? It's not getting enough config to
start by the looks of it. Or it's
getting a dodgy flag which we're probably skipping
because of all scroll.
Yeah. I was looking through this. I I
actually absolutely love the cubelet service failed with
the result exit code.
Perfect. That that was so helpful.
Yeah. I can't think of the start and
all this mess. Let's
I was scrolling through it. Let's create some
blank blank space because blank space is good.
There's a new restart.
Where's my black space?
Oh, there we go.
Okay. So restart counter is it's restarting 8,000
times.
There's some deprecated flags.
I don't wait. Failed to parse
a kubelet flag. Invalid argument.
File check frequency. Okay.
Yeah. You're looking at the same thing. Yeah.
Alright. Let's find that failed check frequency.
Assuming it's not in the
kubelet.
It is.
Oh,
in fact, even our Kuplet fail has a
run once. You sneaky devil.
The mid blot was just to throw his
off as set. So he definitely watched last
one.
I don't need to do a daemon reload,
but I'm gonna do one because now I've
got this here.
And that restart took a bit longer. So
hey.
Alright. Let's give that thirty seconds. See if
we get a ready status.
Alright.
Here we go.
Thank you, Kevin.
That was fun.
That was good.
Alright. I feel vindicated that if I had
been typing, I would have cat ed the
cubelet.
So thank you, Kevin. I feel better about
myself as
yeah.
Alright. Well,
let me close
that session.
And,
let's see. Kevin's saying,
kinda sad that one break didn't stick.
It should have been a system resolved the
break.
Well,
that just means you've got a break for
next time. Right? So it's all good.
And Kevin has already posted a link to
his GitLab repository with the breaks, so and
the Discord server. So if you wanna know
more, go check it out.
Alright. Let's jump over. I I don't know
if Russell's taunting us or not. These guys
are obviously pros, but we're gonna tackle Russell's
cluster now.
He's been hyping this up. So I'm expecting
great,
great things.
I've woken up each morning to a series
of tweets
taunting us. So I have his tweets up
just so that we can go through them
as reference material for, you know
Yeah.
Alright.
We've landed into a speak and spell.
Wait.
Do we have root? I'm concerned we don't
have root. Well, right now, I think our
shell has been replaced by
something else.
We're probably gonna have to try and get
out of it
if we wanna get
access.
Alright. I'm joining.
I'm in.
Oh, I just killed it.
I control c to to see if it
would just
give me a proper shell.
Assuming maybe he just modified the bash profile
to run another command immediately.
Can we just type exit?
Oh.
What noise did Hoot.
Us.
I don't trust that we're still in the
I was gonna say, I don't actually trust
that we're in
in Bash right now.
Yeah. We're not think we're still I
think we're still in the
game.
I think we're still in the game too.
We run Bash?
Okay. So Rust said you'll both love it.
It's written in Rust. So we all know
that Rust is the
I got it. Superior language.
You're just running bash inside of whatever this
is?
It would appear so.
I'm not contained. We have access to the
host.
Quick.
What's happening?
Oh, yeah. Let me reset the clock. Good
call. So whenever I do shift a key,
something breaks.
Export.
Oh, that's interesting. Our bash.
So I don't know that you're in bash.
Russell bash.
Right. I I think that you're in a
special.
You're in a special.
Okay.
Where? So
I love that there's a user code victim,
which I'm assuming we may have ended up
oh, there we go. There's error.
So let's set the crap out of this.
Right?
So end line
And I see it's just had
we have ah,
open.
Oh, I need to go to the terminal
here because that's annoying.
I can't open Vim. Right? So
Can you escape Vim?
He's made it so that oh, I'm assuming
he's taken over a read line and when
I do a single exclamation mark in Vim,
it was done too, but that could have
been a side effect. So we can open
Vim, which means we can edit
password d.
And this is probably just Ben Bash. Right?
I would have thought so.
It's an interesting place for Bash.
Well, aren't we still in?
So we've modified the password for now.
I'm assuming
we can get out of his game
with a new session. And reconnect with a
new session.
Alright. So that was
that didn't get me where I wanted.
I could your code, Russell.
Yeah. Oh, okay.
I will
gaggle.
No. Rip it.
Weak.
Alright. Now we're back in this dodgy r
bash.
If we look at passwords
It's back. It's back. Right. Okay. So
Did we validate that we actually saved it?
Just as a like
is what we did correct?
Or did he revert it? I think that's
two different problems.
I feel, knowing Russell, that he reverted it.
But
Yeah. It's not saved.
Okay.
Let's see what our fail system looks like.
What permissions do we have?
Do we have
I mean,
says that we're root, but I actually don't
believe that we're root.
I'm kind of wondering if we're like, our
bashes root.
No. I don't know. I mean, we can
do cat,
proc,
self,
c grip.
And what else do we want? I mean,
the fact that I'm even in a profile
system, I think
I do believe we are root.
But is this the system's profile system or
is this some container that you're in?
This this is not a container.
This is his shell
on the root of the host. And our
bashes are part of the real thing. He
didn't make it.
So
but I'm not gonna look that up right
now. I'm gonna focus on destroying it with
fire.
So
Oh, it's the restricted bash shell.
Okay. So
our bash is a real thing.
I didn't realize this was it. Okay. So
one second. If we're in the restricted
Well, can we just open a normal bash?
No. Okay. So
now specify slash and command names, but can
I move to the directory? No. Okay. No.
Can set plus r maybe.
I think it's plus r if you do
here, I'll type really quickly.
Do we have access to sudo?
Wait. Wait. Okay. We're done. That's it.
Okay. I can see the and I can
open
binaries with a slash.
So
we currently have real root.
Okay.
Because we had access because sudo is a
set uid binary.
So
well, at least I'm assuming so right now.
I I don't really know what Russell's got
in store for us, but
I really wanna focus on this password fail
because I want my normal shell back.
So what I'm gonna do is
grab for that speak shit.
I'm gonna stick bash over the top of
it.
That makes sense?
Let's stick this to temp. It should just
be bin bash. Right? Yeah. We we just
want bin bash. We don't want his dodgy
bash.
Oh. There's some weird input things going on
right now.
Yes. It really doesn't like me entering a
key.
So copy
binbash. I'm gonna try and copy and paste
this then.
So annoying.
Okay. We need to find a way to
do it. That's the key. Although, let me
move it out of the way, didn't it?
I moved it to
oh, so if I auto complete it. So
temp BeaconShell
and then come back
to user bin
and copy
bin bash to that location.
Alright.
So
let's restart our shell and see if we
get presented with that annoying fucking quiz.
Oh, we're back to them now.
Stage two. Rawkode success. Oh, auto logout.
That's
interesting.
I bet you were back in the Speakeasy.
Alright. So I think we just have to
take commands every fourteen seconds or whatever stupid
release got for us.
Oh, no. It it just
there we go.
Russell, that's that's annoying. You need to log
in and hit the hints really quickly.
Well, no. We don't want the hints. We're
we're just heading level two. Come on. Alright.
So one second. You're in home victim.
Okay. So my guess is that there's something
in the like bash sh
for the profile.
Yeah. I kinda wish I had to speak
easy. The speak and spell back for a
minute.
Let's install a new shell.
Oh, good.
I'll just keep typing.
Alright. We don't have at.
Yeah. Russell up the time. Come on.
Okay. So you think it's in the bash
RC?
Don't know that it is.
I think you as
I think you might be right.
I mean, with that aggressive of a timeline,
it tells me that it's something he thinks
we can get to quickly.
Well, that's the infective's
bash r c, so that's useless.
Okay. Cat profile.
It's either in the bash RC or bash
profile where I've seen the time out. Yeah.
There's here we go. So
we've got
he's used the profile
to fuck with us. Okay.
So in theory, we can just remove that
profile.
Or
delete that really quickly.
You got twenty seconds.
Go.
Okay. So now, hopefully.
No. We're still a victim.
Sure. We didn't
but hopefully we just don't get logged out
quickly.
I think we will. The fact because that
temp that
temp profile is what I thought was making
us the victim.
Wait. Can we just switch users to root?
Yeah. But I'm pretty sure our session is
still gonna get cut off. Let's see.
But if you switch to root and you
don't keep the current session
Yeah. That seems alright. Good call.
Okay.
And I can type k now.
Would you look at that?
Oh, well.
Alright.
Whatever.
Level three, maybe? We don't have a control
plane.
We don't have a control plane. This this
I can deal with better than the previous.
Well, I'm gonna install my my my tool
chain now.
No. I think I've actually got a real
shell.
I prepared my Rawkode. Live. Oh, fuck.
Script.
No curl.
Okay. But but check this out. Look at
where that was. That was user local sbin
bash.
Did he uninstall
apt?
Alright. One sec.
Could you check what are what we're in?
Are we actually in bash?
That shell at the top makes me hurt.
So Ben Bash looks legit.
Is it?
Let's try it. Is Bash not just another
Speakeasy shell?
I I don't think so because the time
oh, I mean, could've changed the timestamp, but
it depends on his his sneaky thing.
Let's see if that saves this time.
Yeah. That's not saving.
It almost feels like we're in an immutable
file system.
Oh, yeah. Russell says we copied bash to
his beacon shell. So he's right. We did
do that. Which means the only way that
he could be modifying our environment now is
through
the profile stuff here,
which we removed.
Or by a rogue process.
And he may just have fucked with the
path.
Oh, yeah. There's no apt.
We've been to.
We do have d p q g,
and he didn't remove apt get.
Alright.
I'm gonna install
Carl this way.
Can you install apt that way? I don't
know. I've never tried. Well, I think it's
well, actually,
curl is already installed.
So he's hidden them.
Interestingly though,
where
apt get is looking,
it knows that it's already installed.
Or he Yeah. So there's a varlib
cache.
Var cache.
And then we could go into
at
and then we have the archives.
We have a whole bunch of devs here,
but the curl one is not there, unfortunately,
because that's not been as that was part
of the base image.
No aliases.
I mean, we could try unset curl.
Yeah. It's not installed.
I'm curious, Russell. Did did you just delete
the binaries?
Because it feels like you've just deleted the
binaries,
which means
But then how did Okay. He's moved it.
That's what he he's moved it. Okay.
We don't need Carl. We we'll we'll make
do with that. I can get my tools.
So
But apt get
What
I want is my
these.
OS query.
Need to add the repository for that. That
may be a pain in the ass.
May as well show people my script.
Since he's made it, so that I can't
use it.
And I can I can still run these
ones?
Was it still doing something?
Although you told me that we don't think
Russell's used after
though. Right? So maybe I don't even need
all these tools.
Well, I don't know. Russell's also the type
to make you think that he didn't use
something, so you don't check it.
Although I haven't seen anything that makes me
think that. Although I guess a lot of
times I think eBPF is used for networking,
but that's not entirely the case.
You could do something else with it.
Sure. I did the last query, right? Can
you ping Google?
Yeah. Well, I mean, I'm heading to Bintas
repositories
and stuff. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Never mind.
Alright. At least I've got some of my
tools.
You have been What just happened? Why have
I got nine, Kat?
It actually shows up better on my screen,
by the way.
It actually shows up properly. Yeah.
That's annoying.
Alright. Let's just get rid of that.
Wherever the nightcap was, it was ignoring the
control c signal, but I managed to control
z to suspend it. We seem to be
okay. Which I'm assuming I can bring it
back whenever I want. So
just for the laughs.
Okay.
Did I get my OS query?
No.
I did.
Oh, you did? Oh, never mind. Sorry.
It's really funky on this screen, but we
do have it if we need it. Okay.
WestQuery is a great tool. You can query
everything with SQL syntax.
Pretty sweet.
Alright. Where were we?
No control plane.
Okay. Let's fix that.
Is that the IP address?
It's the right port number.
Well well, one second. It's the default port
number. I don't know if it's the right
port number port number.
It looks alright.
We're pointing it to
admin.com.
What is
is it configured to
bind to? So like, we could check the
API server config.
Yeah, good idea.
Let's use less or shared picture.
Alright. So
he has it bound to 1072147
here
as the advertise.
And then okay. I don't wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. The
etcd server.
Yeah. That's okay.
Yeah. Can we actually just look at
the container run time, see what
run is running?
Just because we don't act can't access it
doesn't mean it's not running.
Well, let's see if the kubelet's running first.
Thanks.
Thanks, Crystal.
Kubelet is loaded, but not active and running.
Can we just enable it?
Well, it has an exit code from six
seconds ago, so I'm assuming it's crashing.
Oh, but it doesn't have any logs.
Perfect.
I'm gonna change the path ordering to get
rid of that nonsense.
So
let's reexport our path
with
equals
Ben,
user Ben,
user local Ben.
Now anybody that's just watching, I want to
assure you this is not your normal breaks
that you see.
So that should
allow us to do
yeah. Okay. So
I failed to construct a cubelet, unable to
load the CA.
Alright. So we're messing some certs.
Oh, you messed with the certs. I thought
that that's worse than messing with our shell.
Don't mess with our certs.
Can you check the permissions on it maybe?
I don't know.
Sorry. Kupla is saying it cannot open at
the Kubernetes p kica.c
r t.
Appears
that that fail is fine.
He set a temporary fail system to read
only on the slash etsy directory.
Sneaky.
I do believe somebody said like twenty minutes
ago, it felt like we were on a
read only file system.
That looks to be the only change.
It's nice to be able to run commands
without getting nine c metrics.
Just I'm just throwing that out there. It
feels nice. I don't know. I kind of
wish my terminal just randomly every once in
a while threw it out there while it
was working. You know?
Actually, okay. So that's a new project. We
need a a Rawkode
project is like every
hour,
your terminal the next command will give you
a nine cat just to like get you
up and moving.
I think it's a feature.
Didn't seem to fix it.
Oh, it's still there.
Oh, you get the tool. Shit.
It came back. We're gonna go back to
it. It feels like we're on a read
only file system.
One second. I have a command.
Yeah. So it's not making that modification.
This is what we had with the password
file.
Can you do a
d h dash
capital t f?
T f t, sorry. T.
Oh. Oh. D h isn't found. Sorry. Never
mind. That won't that won't change anything.
Our file system looks alright.
And in fact,
I can rate files. So either of them
is compromised.
Did did he just recompile them?
I have something running out there.
Oh, my OS query seems to have
landed a second state.
Alright. I need to admit the lock fail.
Good thing I know Damian alright.
Although, maybe not well enough.
No. I know it's telling me it wants
the path to have that. I don't want
the path to have that.
I'm gonna assume he's he
says he's not recompiled
them.
Oh, okay. And this is recompile?
Yeah. I think our is okay.
Alright. So then how would he
keep us from changing the file system? If
the file system isn't a read only file
system,
and Vim is okay.
Do I still have? And Vim complains if
you don't have the permissions to change it.
It doesn't just silently fail, generally. Generally speaking.
Well, let's try editing it with another command
and see if that works.
So set
and lane
and we want to remove
what was the
It was the run once. Tempest Oh, no.
It's the file system. Sorry.
The read only.
Okay. So we wanna do s
search.
You have a capital y. Star
or dot star slash
remove
is it I e I?
Maybe we don't need to search.
Used to be okay with this third nonsense.
Don't make me bust it peril.
Third.
Yeah. Let's just look it up. I don't
need to.
Set replace.
That delete lane. There's not I'm sure there's
a nice easy way to do that.
So we can just tell it the lane
number.
That's nice. I didn't know that.
So
kubelet
said,
And it's Lane 12345678910,
D,
Kiblet.
Nice. And now we need it to be
in lane.
Take that, Russell.
Nice. Yeah.
The
file attributes. He could have put the immutable
file attribute on it. That was I was
trying to go through the ideas of
Yeah. The attributes look alright.
Okay.
Alright. Do you think we have a cubelet
yet?
No.
Oh, I I stand corrected.
Maybe.
Do we have an API server?
No. Do we have anything, QB?
The kubelet.
Can you check if we have etcd?
We don't seem to have any static manifest
yet.
So we can check the kubelet config to
see if he screwed with the path that
it looks for the static manifests.
Do you wanna check?
Pardon? Do you wanna check?
Sure.
Let's see. We're going to run
where is the config file for etcd?
Barleb
kubelet config dot yaml.
Where did you say? Sorry. I was not
listening. Barlib kubelet config dot yaml. Alright.
You're gonna use Vim? Brave.
True. I'm just gonna add it because it's
probably a binary.
If he does that to you, I'm I'm
not gonna stop laughing.
But I'm sure he wouldn't.
And James said maybe Vem is just a
read only quote. I don't know how you
would do that, but
maybe. I have no idea. I don't know
what's going on with them, to be honest.
Do we not have a viral kubelet? Maybe
there. Cool.
So
fig.yaml
here.
This looks
acceptable,
but let's look through that.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Where
is the okay. Here's Etsy Kubernetes manifest. So
this is the static pod path, the thing
we were looking for, is correct.
Yeah. This looks about right. I'm happy with
that. Do we do we have do we
have any Kube stuff yet?
The search file here is fine.
I think this looks fine to me.
Maybe we're just impatient.
No. We weren't. Is the v one beta
one actually the is it still not in
v one, the Kubelet config?
No.
We do have a kubelet,
although
that's been running for a couple of days.
So
maybe we need to look at the maybe
these manifests aren't real.
The kubelet should did we check the logs?
Like, a journal CTL of the log? Because
the kubelet should complain if there's a parsing
error.
Okay. So it says if not present. I
don't know. Maybe we wanna image pool policy
of always.
But the image image looks correct here.
Russell says he made two changes,
and we only caught one. So let's cut
that unit fail again.
We've obviously missed something here.
We have eight minutes.
Let's check the flags.
Oh, look at that.
Oh.
Okay. So we just need to delete that
without Vim.
How would you cat with lane numbers again?
Does it dash n?
Yeah. And then this said I delete
crap. Did you screw up Vim that way?
If you didn't he said he didn't recompile
Vim.
I need to know.
Well, let's check out the
the RC.
So he's over he's changed.
Oh.
Oh. Hey, that's gone.
Let's restart the computer. We
should have looked there. Yeah, we should have.
But we assumed the worst. We assumed he
had compiled his own Vim. So
Okay. So anybody that doesn't know, I went
against Russell one time and he basically recompiled
everything.
So whenever I think of Russell, I think
that he's recompiled stuff, which he probably used
against me.
Alright. It's not starting.
Our static manifest still.
Error getting node generally is just that etcd
hasn't
connected yet. Right?
Yeah. Well, it's failing to start the scheduler.
Well, there's no API servers. Maybe that's all
maybe it kind of expected.
Right. Because the API server is the only
thing that's gonna touch etcd, which is where
it's gonna find its node.
And we've got an event here.
Connect connection refused.
Unable to register node with API server.
I'm not seeing anything.
Okay.
So
we we we can do this. It's not
starting our API server. We don't even know
if it's trying to start our API server.
Passing glance on that manifest tells me that
it's
it's alright.
Run to default.
The yeah. It looks
I I mean, yeah, I don't know the
whole manifest file, but it looks fine to
me.
I feel like we're missing something in the
kubelet start up, so I'm gonna restart it.
There must be an error message.
Kubelet has to have an error message on
why it's not
starting it.
Okay. So here's this. I'll stop scrolling.
Should have passed through a pager.
One second. One second. Failed to create container
d task. Failed to create shim. OCI runtime
caused unknown container ID.
So it's failing to
talk to the OCI runtime.
I can't I can't see
it. I'm just gonna restart. It still starts
being on me again. I hope that's alright.
That's fine. Go for it. Alright. Control c.
Let's see.
So you see something about container d in
here?
Yeah. Yeah.
I've never actually seen this error before, but
it's saying the
let's see. The kubelet is playing start container
from runtime service failed,
failed to create container tasks, failed to create
shim,
OCI runtime
create failed contain starting container process caused
getting the final child's PID from
pipe caused end of file unknown,
container ID,
UID.
Do we have any containers running in the
container runtime? Can we like
I mean, is container d running?
Wait. Wait. Wait. Okay. There is a read
only true here in volume mount. Oh, no.
This is fine. Never mind.
Alright.
Let's try.
That that error almost seems to be the
controller manager, though, not the
I see that for as
well.
So
so we do have some
two days ago.
C t r c l s.
No containers whatsoever on container d.
We only have one image.
Let's check the container DLOG. Something.
Failed to create shim. Why would it fail
to create the shim? OTSCI runtime create failed.
So
getting the final child pid
child's pid from pipe caused end of file
unknown.
Well, container d doesn't have any configuration.
So this is a standard container d.
Can you search the files in the manifest
for the word unknown?
Okay.
Just a thought. I'm gonna restart container d.
Could we actually, we could check for a
container d
configuration file. There shouldn't be one. Right? There
isn't one.
Okay.
So EOS unknown typically happen
The quote at the end of unknown is
causing me
pain because the the line
there,
it it's doesn't have a starting quote.
It it it does, but it's not on
the it's on the field. It's a structured
log. So it's here on the error.
Oh, okay. Okay. I get it.
Okay. So if we run the status on
this well, we are at a time, but
we're gonna we're gonna fix this sucker. So
we do have a bunch of shims with
the Kubernetes namespace.
I never actually provided the namespace when I
did the CLI.
Let's try that.
Oh, we do have containers. Okay.
Wait a second.
We have a cube controller manager,
Scheduler.
Is this all running in like is there
two run
two namespaces?
Like is it running in a different one
than what cube CTL is hitting?
Let's try and grab some logs. I I
don't know. That's my bad, sir.
There's no
log
back around.
Let's try and inspect one of those.
And I guess the API server is the
one we care about, which
okay. That one definitely isn't there.
The controller manager is.
The controller manager, the a p or the
scheduler I saw, but the API server I
didn't see.
Oh, and full night inspect.
Wait. Is it me or does it just
But we don't have a controller manager running,
do we?
This is why I feel like it's a
shadow
namespace or something.
But you're right that
PS should see that.
You could have broke run c.
Which container
Let's put dash l on that.
Have any of these been modified? No.
Did I get my BPF tools earlier?
Oh, we should, I guess, check kernel modules
loaded.
I want my tools now.
He's annoyed me.
Oh, wait. That's didn't work because of
It's trying to run c metrics again.
So
the path has been modified.
Why is the app get using
c metrics system d?
We removed the profile directory.
I don't know of any other way to
set
the path at the the global level
besides that.
Right?
So we're already have modified the path.
Can we just
delete the things out of s spin that
have been modified recently
and put s spin back in the path?
We'll find a few of them here.
Environment.
Is there a local I mean, I guess
I can also just remove system d and
journal and stuff from that, but then I
don't know how many
Right.
These modified.
But I need I want the app to
get to work.
I was gonna say if we can install
the BPF tool,
we can scan for
Well, I wanna modify I wanna see what
files are being opened by processes.
What what's your idea?
I was just gonna look for kernel modules
loaded, like eBPF programs.
Yeah. We can run BPF trace too.
This is one of the most
annoying breaks we've seen. Right?
There is
there are? There there are. There are hints
in the home directory, but I'm not sure
we need it quite yet, but just
throwing that out there. I know that
Not giving him the satisfaction.
I I was gonna say, I feel like
for Russell, we can't use his hints because
Why is that calling that again?
When I delete that fail. It I've had
enough of it now.
This one.
The user s been? Yeah.
Good.
I'm not as good with I I am
super glad you're dealing with that.
I I did it. Okay.
No. It doesn't. It doesn't install it.
It keeps pulling up that really
where was that again? It's been
does it come back?
No.
So how when I run an app, is
it getting that c metrics?
Maybe from journal control. So I just need
to list everything and user
has been
grep for
April 20.
April '20 '1 maybe?
Internal control seems alright.
They all have the same date at this
point. Right?
Yeah. He's not He's reset the dates,
which is also annoying.
Just talking now. Like, he's sneaky.
Okay.
But they're not installed.
Oh, because I've removed the s pen from
my path now.
Correctly.
This is the one I wanted.
Alright.
So special is any reader rate on the
fail system.
Not sure about that. Log extra fields on
the service. Really, because I don't trust the
Kiplet service yet.
Now Kiplet is reading the static manifest.
That seems
normal.
Alright. What was your idea?
Effectively, this. This looks
fine.
I I was going to run
there's a
BPF
tool,
and then you could give it the prog,
which will list all the eBPF
programs.
Yep. We can do that with bpf trace.
That was my only
I don't know. That was my thought
as far as
seeing if there's any rustle
Russell code in the kernel.
Well, there's definitely a lot of e b
p f going on, but we also have
a cilium on this cluster.
The new cilium does use e b p
f, so that should be like
that should be fine.
Yep. I mean, we could look for things
that are suspicious.
He he also told us that his hack
doesn't work. So right now he's I'm pretty
convinced he's broken container d.
Alright. So how would you break container d?
There's run c,
which is how container d runs applications on
the host. It kind of takes care of
the the stuff. How would you break run
c? There's namespaces
and
c groups and the things that it does
with the kernel calls.
I've never actually touched configuration
of run c. Can you configure run c?
Let me let me Google that.
I don't think so when you're using the
containerd shim, but please check because
we're into uncharted territory for me as well.
Yeah.
I'm gonna
apt get install reinstall container d.
And we checked that there was no container
d configuration file. Right? There
Yeah. I did that container d config dump
and we got nothing. And Russell was
basically till I reinstalled Container d before telling
me he hasn't touched Container d. So, you
know, thanks.
Let's read this error message properly. Run pod
sandbox
for kubectl server. This is the one we
care about.
Failed to create a container d task,
failed to create a shim, the OCI runtime
create failed,
getting the final child's PED from the pipe.
Okay. So
I am gonna use a little s squid
in there.
Oh, it's gonna be not working because of
the screen size.
Alright. I'll just do a PSN.
K. So there's actually a
there's actually a GitHub issue
for this,
the exact error.
It was a configuration
okay. So system CTL had a max user
namespaces.
So as I was saying, possibly
messing with namespaces,
Like, restricting the number of namespaces?
Russell says bingo.
I don't know.
So we're restricting the namespaces via system d?
Here. Can I type Yep? Please. Go for
it.
Parameter.
You're right. It's a kernel parameter. It's like
because namespaces are part of first
before you go right into it.
Okay.
So this
system control
grep have type grep
for namespaces.
Because I'm curious of what he's tampered with.
That's not on our path anymore, so you'll
need to
Okay. Okay. I got it. Sorry.
Russell.
Okay.
I just I'm gonna go to the user
as
guess we're going to the dash Yeah.
And grip.
Oh. Oh, yeah. I'm a dumb dumb.
Oh, yeah. Max code name SpaCy7.
That's a very specific number.
Alright. Let's pull it that way.
So let's actually just update it to the
rest of these. Oh, shoot. I did
I opened debugging tools. One second.
Oh, okay. You got it.
Alright.
Probably have to restart container d. Although you
could we can run a PS, I guess,
and see if we start to see things
showing up.
Like, grab the cube and see if we've
got any control plane component.
Controller manager. That's
it.
It's coming.
Oh, Russell.
I
that was good. Messing with the
the system settings.
Actually Restart
the cue ball to speed us up.
Educational break. I I really like it because
it's it's talking about namespaces,
c groups, how
how containers are actually run. That's that's brilliant.
Good one.
I appreciate that one.
Do we have an API server yet?
Just coming. Okay.
It was there.
Let's go check the log.
No. I have containers.
Oh, okay.
Apparently, we're halfway through.
Oh, no.
But now we're hopefully talking Kubernetes land, so
it should be easy breaks.
Alright. Varlog containers.
Sorry. Oh, Varlog. That's
that's in the wrong place.
And then cube dash API.
Failed to find any PEM data on certificate
input. So this looks like he messed with
the certificate data.
Alright. Let's
go check the steps.
So this needs pretty much everything
annoyingly.
Did it say which one it unlocks?
So this says the t l cert file,
the configuration is the API server
dot cert in the PKI.
Well, we just refresh all the certs?
With Kubadian? Yeah.
I think that's the easiest way to do
this is just ask Kubadian to refresh it.
I don't remember the command off the top
of my head. No. I never do.
There.
The configuration file looked fine.
Serps.
Reader.
We could just do all, I guess.
Two changes per broken cert. What does that
even mean, Russell? What does two changes per
broken cert? How many broken certs are there?
How
Alright. So we're gonna have to delete.
Cool.
Now we just check the logs again.
Well, we need to
restart everything.
So temp
Man, man b star.
And move all back.
Do you need to restart the cubelet first?
I mean, we'll do that anyways just to
speed it up.
Where'd that dot EMVRC come from?
Nice catch. Nice catch.
Now
okay. I think we just sledgehammered his fine
break. I think he actually base 64 encoded
data in them.
So if we had actually,
base 64 decoded
his certs.
It was taking us so long.
Guess we still got better.
Oh, it's not regenerated to API server.
To forget for a survey. Alright. We'll regenerate
it.
But that's about to have people with the
RM.
Let's see if we've got what we need
here.
Oh, good. You did that on that too.
Maybe we can't renew.
Can't do we need to generate
the keys and certificate for signing request and
then renew?
Did you delete the signing stuff?
Yeah. I think I deleted too much.
Been there.
Read your
Certificate
for serving the Kubernetes API.
You're annoying me now.
So I'm gonna have to do
and it I remember like there's
An hour ago when I used to have
a friend called Russell.
It's alright. Let's just regenerate everything.
And then we'll have every
PKI.
Yeah. It's better. But now, because we've modified
even the Rawkode
to connect, but I'm alright with that.
Let's
we need to move all the manifest back
again.
Right. We'll have to restart everything now.
Alright.
And we have an API server.
Maybe. Can't be that easy. Can't be that
you just
do get nodes.
No APIs ever flipped.
Okay.
Can't speak to
k.
Oh, did we restart etcd because we gave
it new certs. Right? Yeah.
I need to be a bit more soft
touched with these components I think and
getting some bad habits now.
Well, I do believe that he base 64
encoded
words into those. I don't know if we
would have decoded them.
Can we see the logs for
etcd?
Yeah.
It doesn't like the certificate that it's getting.
Old or new? Old or new? It's like
the hypocrite signed by unknown authority which would
cause me to believe that the root
cert, the what which we changed,
It's either hasn't gotten the new one or
the Kube API server hasn't gotten the new
Yeah. I'm gonna
stop everything.
This is gonna end up in trouble, isn't
it?
Nah. It's fine.
It's fine.
Why is that not working?
So it doesn't think that you provided it
a container.
Oh.
Oh, XRGs. Yeah.
XRGs. That's what I was gonna say. You
have to pass in there you go.
Alright. How do we delete a stop dictator?
Or do I need to just stop it
first? Or we could just run stop first.
So I don't use
CTR very often. Yeah. I I assumed RM
would just have a
Yes. Really delete me flag.
Can you just use
Why don't we try the pods?
I don't wanna use cry control for that.
Pods out there.
Op print
one.
At
n one.
No. Tail n one.
No. How'd you skip the row again?
That doesn't matter.
Right. Control.
Runtime endpoint.
Really should have just set the environment variable.
Stock
pods r m
four.
And egg. Oh, no. That's weird.
Gonna have to tape all that again.
Alright.
Alright. Maybe we're ever thinking this.
Maybe we just screwed up the search.
I don't know. We could we I don't
think we did.
Why is that not deleting them?
Pods only list pods. Yeah. So you have
to do
RMP
force.
Alright.
Now we got very little running.
Star.
Kiplet.
You wanna reset you wanna reset the stairs
one more time or we are we happy
that they're maybe okay?
I think we're fine.
I think I think we did like the
full
you ran the phase
for kubeadm,
which should regenerate everything.
That's annoying.
Alright.
So it still says certificate signed by unknown
authority.
The only thing I can think of is
we need to delete stop the cubelet,
delete the pods,
then redo the certs.
Because maybe one was holding one open and
didn't let it get re reformat
like, rewritten. I didn't
or we didn't notice that it complained that
it didn't rewrite the the cert.
That's like the only thing I can think
of
minus
minus him recompiling the binaries to just complain
about that,
which I'm hoping he didn't do. Alright. Well,
we have now regen all the steps. The
kubelet is currently stopped.
There's no pods running.
Now we restart. Encryption isn't enabled on FTD
to the best of my knowledge.
That would be harsh.
Start. Oh,
Russell telling us to use the hints, but
he said the search are fine. There's a
line message from the API server YAML.
Oh.
A line. You pick one line out of
a hundred lines.
One that's missing? Okay. Yeah. Need to, like,
pull up.
Oh.
Nice call.
I think.
There should be a a certain key for
each one.
Change it to yeah.
The ending. Alright.
Yeah. C a dot key.
And then let's just confirm with
we won't have a Kube API server, will
we?
Well, let's see what the API server says.
That's not what he removed.
Alright.
So I just assumed whenever there's a CA
cert, there's a CA key, but I guess
not. So
it's the insert file, it's the key file.
That looks okay. Right?
Well, if he's going off of removed a
line, it's not that he edited a line.
And we have the kupla client there.
Let me kupla client key.
And we're just assuming that it's one of
the commands.
Let me see if I can't pull up
I'm gonna log in to the other cluster
and pull up this file. One second.
Yeah.
Not?
I mean, we could always end at phase
manifest,
but
Yeah. I'm I'm gonna cheat. I'll be right
back.
Alright.
So
It's an etcd c a file
according to the docs.
Do we not we have a cert file,
a key file, a server.
Oh, okay.
The file.
No. It's looking for the certificate authority.
And what's the path on that?
On your Was that not just p j
I c a dot cert?
I don't know. Is there an entity c
a at all in your Shouldn't it be
the authority that signed all of them? I
think it should be the same authority.
That would be
I guess, etcd could have its own authority.
Oh, it does. Yeah. Okay.
Etcd sees there.
And then we wait.
Nothing.
But maybe I'm being impatient.
Definitely old.
Oh, one second. Can you go back to
that file?
Did you go did you add the one
that was
Well, it's not trying to connect in four
minutes. So I'm gonna restart the keyboard.
What? Which one? Sorry.
No. No. No. You I just you probably
did. There's the you did the c a
cert that's in the Etsy folder, EtsyD folder.
Yeah.
Alright. There we go. We got a new
log.
It's all good?
Okay.
So that just means Alright. Admin.com is using
the old.
Right.
Alright.
Let me do remove
admin.conf.
Q bdm.
There's renew
admin.
Okay.
Can't renew if it doesn't exist. We have
to do
init
phase.
So
I thought we did this.
I thought that the init phase was going
to rewrite the admin
admin comp.
Yeah. It's it's own phase. I just don't
remember. So there's the control play one which
would have done the static manifest.
Could config.
And
we'll
probably need them all actually. Right?
Yeah. I I think so because it's
going to build ones for each of them.
They're actually going to continue to have problems
talking to each other without them.
Alright.
Look at that. Two well, not two hours.
Almost two hours. And we've got a we've
only just run our first script control command.
And we're assuming that the control plane is
actually working. Like, we haven't checked on, like,
the things that are actually running on it.
Just kubelet's happy.
Yeah. I'm just going straight for the
I have to launch BI.
Oh, because our path and everything is
screwed up.
Error
equals
which then
edit
v one.
Feels too easy.
Well, the worker is unhealthy, so it's probably
not gonna be able to schedule it.
Do we really need to go fix this
worker? I'm tired.
I was gonna say, I don't know what
shell we're going to drop into on the
worker because when we logged into this one,
we spent the first forty five minutes
getting into bash.
Logging into the worker. Let's do it. Let's
do it.
Command.
Wordle in the command line. This is fantastic.
Enter your guess. James,
we could untaint the master and that's usually
my favorite trick or manually scheduling the pod,
but we did say to Russell we would
fix the worker.
So and we go.
This was a command. It's not gonna overwrite
the shell set in the password fail.
I'm sure there's a way to tell it
to disregard the login shell.
I don't really want to play Wirtle.
It's five letters
because I guess Russell.
It wasn't Russell. But is it today's actual
Wirtle, or is it his own Wirtle?
Oh, I I don't I've actually never played
Wordle before.
Oh.
So
I also tried I hate you.
Custom mortal. Alright. Okay.
Alright. Let's try.
Words.
Not cubes.
Hello.
Alright. We have an l and an o.
Is that an l and an o in
the word or in those positions?
A green would be in the positions.
Okay. Okay.
How is not in the dictionary?
Why can I not think of any words
with l and o in it? Limbo,
I guess. I
Oh, nice. Okay. It starts with an l.
L o. Okay. There's all my l words.
Logging.
Wait wait. No. That's too long.
Loom.
That has an o and an m. Right?
I freaking I I hate you, Russell.
Wordle.
Shelf.
Must be an a.
Lamps?
How
is lamps not in the dictionary?
Well, you're gonna get a different word. That's
what he's saying, I think.
Oh. Just random pair and location.
Oh,
that's even okay. So I'm I'm not I'm
gonna stop guessing, and I'm just gonna look
at yours.
It has to have an m and an
o.
Lomi,
that is not a word.
Yeah. I would've never gotten that. One second.
Let me look it up. I'm calling BS
on that one.
Okay. Denoting
or relating to a fertile soil of clay
and sand containing
humus.
Really?
I was never good at word, though.
The end might be s e. That's a
a common ending.
Since we have an e, I think that's
a common ending. I'm not really good at
English
being that it's like my third or fourth
language.
It's not definitely not my best language. What's
your first language?
English.
It's my only language. I'm just not very
good at it.
Yes. So that's an all we have to
par is s and e.
I'm just trying to get more layers out
of it, and it's it's
gonna go I think it's just gonna give
us a shit word.
Alright. So can you try these?
Obese. Oh, obese.
Told you, s e.
Oh, nice job.
This is the last one. And then, Russell,
you're gonna have to
help us with this.
Can you actually
I'm going while you're doing that, I'm gonna
try to escape the shell.
I wish I played Wordle.
Okay. Nothing I'm doing is letting me escape
the shell either.
Okay. R and a.
Pratt. That seems fitting.
Alright. Maybe not p r. What goes before
r?
No. Because there is in the middle, Russell.
Could be cramp.
No.
Pram.
Prada.
Dry.
Drums.
Grain.
Oh, we're almost there.
I rate.
Hey, Russell. Do your magic. We won then.
Alright.
That has c d this thing? Yeah. So
you've not broken that at least.
Hey. I actually beat Wordle.
Mine was early.
Alrighty.
Make sure we don't need to do that
again.
Alright. That must have fucked with. That's good.
Now, what is the problem that we have?
We have an unhealthy
yes.
Well, all these search are gone though. Right?
Yeah. Let me join your session. Give me
just a second.
Oh, we're gonna have to regenerate the certs
here.
Yep.
So if we do a j q temp
custom data,
this is all my setup stuff.
Join token is
here.
If we go to
our loop
cloud
instance,
script,
grep
join.
We can run
these two commands
to rejoin the cluster.
DNS name isn't there.
I think this is
yeah.
Okay.
QBDM
reset.
Russell, I just wanna say nice job on
this. This was really well done.
What'd you say? We got from the join
that give us
header.
Oh, check the check the
namespaces.
We haven't got our worker joined to the
cluster yet.
Oh, okay. Sorry. Sorry. For
some reason, whenever I join your session, it's
just not joining your session giving me Russell
on the worker.
Russell worker one.
No. I won't. Yeah.
So it's gonna 145.
It should be going through our default gateway.
Default through here. Not to overwrite it. Oh,
we have an unreachable.
Yeah. Black hole does.
Yep. Yep.
Rawkode.
For you, Russell.
That looks better.
Oh,
did that just segfault?
Oh, DNS lookup failed. And then X509 unknown
certificate. Sorry. I wonder if the join token
was
reset somehow. So what we're gonna do here
is regen
that,
so we can actually ask it for a
new join token.
Create
oh, it's a bootstrap. How do we do
the join token again?
I don't remember. Maybe the generate
join.
Believe it's run on the control plane.
Yeah. It's just a Pretty straight. Yeah. Okay.
Cool.
Could be an AM talking. Great.
There we go.
X four join
token. That makes sense. I think it actually
expires after twenty four hours anyway, so it
probably was bad anyhow.
Yeah.
Yeah. Probably right.
We have to recreate the conflict map. That's
the one that expires after twenty four hours.
Oh, okay. Okay. We have to tell it
to
I knew something expired after twenty four hours.
I I didn't remember which one. And it
is
and this should be an upload. Yep. Config.
Upload service and config.
Let's try config and see if that works.
Well, let's take off the v nine. I'm
a bit more confident now.
Oh, does our black hole come back?
Alright. Let's bring back my v nine.
Okay. So we do need to upload this.
Maybe this there.
So what was the missing?
Please see uploads
there.
We are not pending the certificate key. So,
alright, this isn't working.
The cluster info config map does not yet
contain
a
DWS signature for token ID.
My join token wrong?
I thought you just generated a token. Did
you have to do it after you did
the upload all?
Don't think so.
UDM and it pays out.
You did the backs of the Bootstrap token
for the join node to the cluster.
Okay.
I don't I don't know. I haven't done
this in a really long time. But there's
the bat the bootstrap token that generates a
bootstrap tokens to join the cluster join a
node from a cluster. Yeah. We need to
rerun that one.
It doesn't hurt. Right? So
and then we'll print the join command.
Well, this is essentially what we were running.
Well, that's obviously still complaining with the same
message.
Okay. What does this mean?
It
does not contain a judgment.
Okay.
So
wait. Wait. It's
so weird because the control plane is that's
the token ID of the control plane that
it's printing out.
So it looks right.
Which one are we using? 70 yet. The
yetle?
Yeah. This should be working
unless the problem is
an existing config map.
Well, that's our although it should have been
updated.
I'll see MRM.
What's wrong with that?
Keep control.
No. Keep control doesn't have a remove RM.
It's a delete.
Thank you, Zari. I
mean, some people, I think you could, like,
alias it if you like,
I guess. Alright. So let's upload all the
config maps again.
Alright. Russell says we fixed the root issue.
Regenerate the search may have made us a
bit more difficult.
I really shouldn't have though. That should be
able to join just fine. My token is
fine.
Buying Google.
Yeah. I don't know.
Is there any webhooks on our cluster which
is causing it to fail to join?
Yeah. Actually, I haven't really looked at the
cluster yet.
No.
Alright. I think I'm just gonna bypass this.
I don't
I'm not sure what we have wrong here.
Seems
Because it's speaking to the cluster,
and it's saying the cluster info config map
doesn't have something.
I feel like this is just my lack
of running Cubadian to do this specific thing.
Like Possibly. Possibly there is a
command or something that we're I thought I
thought the upload was the one to do.
Alright. What's in this config map?
It's been a bit weird.
Wait. Wait. Look at that. The JWS cube
config up at the top of that config
map.
It
it's not the same
unless that's base 64 encoded.
Oh, no. I'm just gonna delete this.
That should there should be an alias for
delete on that. Right? Okay.
Here we are. And if it's gonna do
Just the upload cert
or upload config. Upload config. Sorry, I said
certs. I meant
or wait. Which one would it be? Upload
config or upload certs?
Yes. Both.
Alright. So how do we regenerate the cluster
info config map?
Alright. Russell is saying try removing the mount
namespace limit.
I don't know that the namespace limit's currently
a problem.
I thought that may have regenerated it.
Do we need to upload the config or
upload the I'm just bypassing
Oh, never mind.
Okay. I got it. Sorry. I have to
do my kids bedtime soon.
So we'll go with the old hack, bypass
the scheduler.
Schedule on the control plane node?
Yep.
Node name,
Russell
control plan one.
I did edit the deployer. Right?
Let's delete the parts because I probably
put it in a very weird position.
I'm
just deleting the world now.
Oh, we don't have a controller manager for
this stuff, it looks like.
Oh,
that could be in the configuration manifest files,
I guess.
That looks alright.
No. No. I meant, like, did we do
we not have one at all? Like, he
has the manifest
up and running.
I don't know these manifests that well.
Shoot.
Looks alright.
That's not been restarted in a long time,
so it's probably using the the wrong set.
What
else is probably using the the wrong cert.
That should all be alright. I mean, the
schedule over bypassing anyway.
We have a replica set.
We have a pod.
It's in pending.
I've got a node.
What does
oh,
add a node
Russell
control plan one.
I shouldn't have to remove the tenth because
I manually scheduled it. No. Because you directly
scheduled it.
That shouldn't matter.
No. That's just pending for another reason.
Wait. Did you do describe? You did do
describe.
No event.
No events.
Why wouldn't it schedule I mean, we fixed
the namespace issue. The only thing I could
think of is like when we change the
system
is
to restart but I've I find it very
dangerous to restart one of these systems. I
have broken them that way.
We don't need to look at the controller
manager because that's done its job now.
Alright. Keep it. Maybe it needs restarted.
Yeah. It's saying that control plane's not found.
That almost looks like it's not talking to
the API server still.
I see some unauthorized.
Did he touch our back?
I really do need to go in for
my daughter. So let's check out these hents.
Oh, dear. Oh, dear.
Oh, we fixed it all now. Okay.
Alright.
Whatever's broken, I've done it. I think the
problem is
Tripla isn't speaking to the API server.
I think something happened
with our certs when we updated them.
No. Because the Kiplet certs were updated too.
Yeah. Everything in there is is brand
new.
Let's stop the Kiplet.
There are no
So yeah. We actually
untainted the the control play node plus we
directly scheduled it on it. I don't think
that's a problem
as far as the taints and tolerations go.
Unauthorized.
Yeah. I don't know.
Right now it does feel like something with
the certs that we did. Well, like Like,
we
We're two and a half hours in.
I have no idea
what our last thing is. We're fixing a
of Russell's stuff, so that's good.
My mind is a little mooch. You even
beat Orbital, so that was fun.
But let's call it there.
How was that? You have fun?
Oh, it was fantastic.
Thank you, Russell.
That was that was good. Yeah. I think
there was there was a lot of learning
there, although we were a bit heavy handed
with the cluster at times.
Lots of lots of fun stuff, so thank
you for that.
But I'm
gonna go put my kids to bed and
have my dinner and go to sleep crying
like a little baby, I think. So
Alright. Thank you, Kevin. Thank you, Russell, for
breaking two great clusters. Thank you, Marek, for
spending two and a half hours with me
working through this absolute car crash of a
cluster. Thank you to the audience that stuck
with us. I know that was an absolute
long slog,
but lots of great fun. We will catch
you all next time. Thank you to our
sponsors, Equinix Merrill and Teleport.
See you soon. Thanks, Mark. Bye.
Thank you.